- So welcome to the Eighth Annual
Adam and Anne Amory Parry Lecture.
Co-sponsored by the
Departments of Classics
and Comparative Literature.
I'm Ayesha Ramachandran
and on the comp lit end of things,
it's my pleasure to welcome you
and kick things off today
but before I do that,
I want to give a big shout
out to Kirk Freudenburg,
Chair of Classics who is running around
organizing things here for all
of the wonderful arrangements
for today's lecture and
reception that will follow.
Before we start, a couple
of practical matters.
Let me invite you to take this moment
to turn off your cellphones
or at least silence them.
We, this lecture is being
recorded and will be online.
So I just want to give you a heads up
that we hope you will come use the mics
to ask questions at the end
but you will be being
recorded if that is a concern.
And finally, there will be a reception
right after this lecture in Phelps 401
right across Old Campus.
Anyone with a Yale ID
should be able to get into the building,
take the elevator to the fourth floor.
If you aren't sure you
can get into the building,
just tag on to the big group
that I hope will be trundling
over after the lecture
and please stay to celebrate the lecture
and our speaker today.
Okay, so supported by generous gifts
from Professor Gilbert
Lawall and James M. Morris,
the Amory Parry lecture remembers
the husband and wife pair of scholars,
Anne Amory Parry and Adam Parry.
Both trained in classical
literature and philology,
both interested in wider
issues of literary criticism
and the history of ideas.
The Parrys were a formidable team
who ended up teaching at Yale
where he became head of
Classics from 1968 to 1971.
Though they died very young,
their work had already
established them as leaders
in Homeric criticism and the
study of other ancient texts.
Particularly Thucydides and Virgil.
It is in the spirit of their wide ranging,
elegantly written and exciting,
ground-breaking scholarship
that the annual Amory Parry
Lecture brings to Yale
speakers whose work
continues in the traditions
to which the Parrys belonged.
So it is particularly fitting
that today's lecture will
be given by David Quint.
Sterling Professor of
Comparative Literature
and English at Yale.
David tells me that he
remembers the Parrys
and their tragic death
and his own astonishingly
wide-ranging scholarship
which ranges from Homer
to Proust via Virgil,
Tasso, Montaigne,
Shakespeare, Cervantes, Milton
and the Arabian Nights, just
to name a few highlights
emerges from and embodies
the intellectual traditions
of the Parrys.
For many of us in this room,
this is also a moment of
culmination and celebration
to listen to David give the Parry Lecture.
In both Classics and
Comparative Literature,
we have learned from
his immense erudition,
as well as his deeply precise marginalia
on many of our essays.
He has been a sometimes terrifying model
for the intellectual generosity
and scholarly rigor of our fields.
To introduce David properly,
please join me in welcoming
Alessandro Barchiesi,
Professor of Classics
at New York University.
Welcome.
(audience applauds)
- Hello there and what a surprise
that I shouldn't be here.
I don't have a right to speak
because people know you so well.
But it's a fine day.
So I'm just happy to walk around
and I noticed the poster of this event.
So I thought there's really
something I want to tell you
before you start and
it's actually about me.
So also at the end as you might imagine,
because you all know this kind of event.
At the end I will say something
like, David Quint rules
Or David Quint rocks
or David Quint is sick
or whatever the language is
in this kind of occasion.
So my final sentence will
be something like that.
David Quint rules.
But you know, human memory is sedimentary.
So let me go back to the very beginning
of my knowledge of David Quint.
David is now a dear friend of mine
but we don't go very far back.
Initially David was a presence in Pisa
where I was a junior professor
of classics and you know,
we were all free floating
between Pasquale and Armale
and the only good coffee
shop in Pisa, Cafe Salza.
You should try it.
Many of us were interested in a project
which was about the
rejuvenation of classics.
So the idea was basically that classics
was really always behind
the developments of literary
theory and literary criticism
back then in the 80s.
I mean the very first important
paper on imagery in Virgil
by Bernard Knox
came long after similar
studies of Shakespeare.
The very first influential
negative reading of the Aeneid
by Adam Perry was later then
similar experiments on Milton
and so on.
So there was this idea that classics
should try have more of a
dialogue with literary theory
and literary criticism
and when you start your
career it's very important
that you have some kind of
big hope for your field.
What I didn't know is that
one of the interesting answers
was actually a young Professor
of Renaissance Studies
who was walking up and down
with other people like you
and having coffee.
The first thing I noticed
about David is that David,
you know how to pick your friends
and the people you talk to.
You were hanging out with
people I knew to be brilliant
like Lina Bolzoni, Sergio Zatti
and you were talking to Francesco Orlando,
the leading light of Pisa
and literary criticism.
You were laughing at the
jokes of John Beatro Conte
and so on.
But back then, I didn't know that today
we'd have new answers to my quest
and the big shock after that
was the publication of Epic and Empire.
A book that marks a new
step in the tradition
of comparative criticism
because every single chapter
is a protagonist in
discussions of a single author.
Meaning that the chapter on Virgil,
the chapter on Lucan and many others
are now central to critical discussions
of Virgil and Lucan.
It was a bit of a shock for me
because I was hoping
to rejuvenate classics
from the inside out and now I found out
that someone under the flag
of comparative criticism
could achieve so much
in just a single book.
After that I have had more
attention to your production
and I came to realize that you
are an authority in Milton,
Cervantes, Montaigne, Tasso, Ariosto.
So every time you enter a field,
you change the conversation
in that specialized field.
We all say negative things
about specialization
but it's also true that
this approach to scholarship
has created very competitive
arenas for discussion
and regularly David is a
protagonist and a leader.
So I obviously look forward
to what you're going to say today.
I just want to add that David
is actually a rich person
and also a citizen.
I was surprised to learn about that
because so many leading
scholars I have met in my career
are not really engaging
reality as we know it.
Now David has been active in reforms
and serious changes at Yale.
He knows a lot about politics
and he has a strong sense of realpolitik.
He was the only person,
the only friend to tell me
that Donald Trump was going
to win the 2016 elections.
You know blue state, in academia.
People were not, even if they knew it,
they would not say that to me.
I am reminded that David's father
was an important scholar
of American history.
So there are a number of things
that I know about you now
after reading Epic and Empire
and after meeting you in Pisa.
But the only important thing
is that David Quint rocks.
(audience applauds)
- We can go home now.
Very difficult to follow
that or live up to it.
Thank you Sandro.
I want to thank Ayesha
Ramachandran and Kirk Freudenburg
for the invitation to
give this lecture in honor
of Adam and Anne Parry
and I feel very honored
to speak in their memory.
I also want to thank both
Departments of Classics
and Comparative Literature
for offering me this occasion
but also all of the
collegiality and friendship
they have given me over my years at Yale.
I was, in recent memory, a
convenor of this lecture series
with Christina Kraus
whom I wish especially to
thank for team teaching with me
on Virgil's Aeneid.
A really precious experience
which is reflected in today's talk.
This talk is part of
a larger essay article
which is simply too
long for a single talk.
I've tried to cut it down
to a manageable 50 to 55 minutes.
It is like other work I have published,
an attempt at a bird's eye
view of the epic tradition
but it is more complicated
when it's seen down on the ground.
Its polemical cast is gonna be clear
from the very beginning.
Does epic have a future tense?
A now familiar critical idea
advanced by Mikhail Bakhtin
relegates epic to an archaic, closed past
and to a fixed univocal meaning.
Against this strawman
Bakhtin defines the novel
as dialogical, meaning
speaking to the present
and open to the future.
It's fine for the novel.
It's the kiss of death for epic
and for the most part it's bullshit.
In the written text it's baloney.
Beginning with the Odyssey
and looking back on the Iliad,
epic poems look back from a later moment
on their predecessors and
models and in doing so,
they imagine how a later moment,
a future will look back on them.
This retrospection projection
becomes more intense
as epic moves historically
from the Homeric oral archaic world
to first Hellenistic and Roman epic
and then another millennium later
to the writing of epic
poems along classical models
in the Renaissance.
Beginning with the Odyssey
too and then repeated
as a topost in poem after poem,
epic presents a scene
that creates distance,
temporal and historical
upon its heroic fiction
that breaks out of its past
which was never the absolute,
self-contained past wrongly
described by Hegelian critics.
This particular type scene
is the hospitality and banquet
that the Phaeacian king Alcinous
offers to Odysseus at Scheria
in books eight through 13 of the Odyssey.
And the similar welcome
and banquet modeled on the Odyssey episode
that Dido gives for Aeneas at Carthage
in books one and three of the Aeneid.
To arrive at a Scheria or a Carthage
is the kind of time travel into the future
through a wormhole that
opens out of the epic world.
These episodes project a
world and audience foreign
to its heroic world that is
also an alternative future
or modernity.
The world of its later readers.
We readers are to see ourselves invited
to the epic banquet and
as part of the poem's
internal addressees.
It is assumed that we
readers in the future
may or may not share the
heroic ethos of Martial epic.
Ties as it is to an now-archaic society.
We are asked to measure our
own values versus that ethos
for better or for worse.
This Scheria, Carthage topic
contains some of the following elements.
His host grants to the
wandering hero a safe harbor,
at least a harbor that
initially seems to be safe.
The hero tells the story of his history
and adventures at a
banquet given in his honor.
The host already appreciates
stories of the hero.
The Phaeacian singer Demodocus recounts
the fighting at Troy.
The Carthaginians have
depicted Aeneas in the scenes
of the Trojan war on the temple of Juno.
The two heroes weep at these stories
but the hosts have made them into objects
of aesthetic entertainment.
The hosts, the Phaeacians and
the Phoenicians of Carthage
live in a society that appears
less heroic and warlike
but more materially advanced,
more scientifically and
technologically developed
than the hero's own.
The hero is already part of
a past that is half mythical
and as Odysseus himself
described in his storytelling
it's consigned partly to an underworld
and to partly a dead past.
The hero is in fact invited
to leave his own world.
Perhaps to get with the living present
and the way of the future.
Through marriage with the local princess.
Alcinous offers to wed
his daughter Nausicaa
to Odysseus and Dido goes further.
She starts an affair with Aeneas
and declares herself his wife.
The seafaring Phaeacians
are wealthy sophisticates,
unwarlike, vaguely effeminate.
Their queen Arete seems
to be their real ruler.
They are better at dancing
with a ball than at athletics.
Sir Moses Finley speaks of Scheria
as a kind of utopia and
indeed beneath a thin,
poetic disguise Phaeacian
society appears to contain
what Finley has revered elsewhere
to be conspicuously absent and excluded
from the noble households of the Odyssey.
Trade on the one hand and
the art of metalworking.
The two are connected.
From metals were the most
important commodities
of ancient merchants.
The wealth of Alcinous
and his landed aristocracy
officially depends on the
fabulous fertility of Scheria
and one Phaeacian
nobleman insults Odysseus
by telling him that he
resembles a merchant seaman,
a man of business grasping for profits.
But it is the Phaeacians themselves,
Nausicaa has told Odysseus
who have no concern
with the bow and quiver but
is all mass and oars of ships
in the balanced vessels themselves
in which they delight
in crossing the Gray Sea
and that should be on
this very long handout
which gives an idea of
just how much of this
you have to endure.
And indeed the Phaeacians
appear to have magic ships
that not only move swift as thought
or as winged creatures but seem
to understand men's thoughts
and purposes and they know
all the cities of men.
That is, the Phaeacian
ships and their masters
have navigated the entire Mediterranean
and they bear more than
a passing resemblance.
Both in their wealth and in their name
to the despised Phoenecian traders,
harbors of men's goods
who crop up repeatedly
in Odysseus' lying stories in
the second half of the poem.
And also, in Eumaeus' own life story.
Homer also transfers to Scheria
the metalworking wonders
of the Iliad's Hephaestus.
Outside the palace of Alcinous,
itself adorned with bronze
walls, silver columns
and golden doors stand
dogs of silver and gold.
Fashioned by Hephaestus
to stand watch over the palace.
Being themselves immortal,
in all their days they are ageless.
And it's hard to know whether
these dogs are mere statues
like the torch-bearing
young men made of gold
inside the palace
or whether they are automata
like those in the shape of young women
who serve in Hephaestus'
Olympian Palace in the Iliad,
in Iliad 18.
The Phaeacian singer
Demodocus sings two songs
about the Church at war.
The second song culminates
with the fighting around
the House of Deiphobus, the
second Trojan husband of Helen.
In between,
he tells about Hephaestus'
straying wife Aphrodite
and her lover Ares.
Ares who has won her, both with gifts
and with his splendid person.
Hephaestus traps the couple
in a net so finely
wrought as to be invisible
and this song defines, excuse me,
he traps them in a net that
is so fine as to be invisible.
This song defines a
Phaeacian subject matter
as opposed to the matter of epic.
Hephaestus' metallurgical technae
overcoming the god of war himself.
One doesn't need to fight a Trojan War
over an adulterous wife,
nor write an Iliad about it.
The divine smithy demands repayment
of his epic courtship gifts sorry
and Poseidon agrees to make sure
that Ares pays the adulter's damages.
These are how such matters
are handled on Olympus
and in a civilized, wealthy society
like that of the Phaeacians.
The story anticipates the
entrapment of Penelope's suitors,
minus virtuous Penelope herself
through the craftiness of Odysseus
in the Odyssey's second half.
But in contrast, it makes
the bloody ending of the poem
feel like something like a recrudescence
of an atavistic epic violence.
It also expresses an all-too human view
of the Olympian gods.
A measure of the skepticism
that may accompany the,
excuse me.
The materialist outlook of the Phaeacians.
The smithy Hephaestus
is their kind of god.
In the aftermath of Troy,
the Odyssey depicts a world
that is already post-heroic
measuring the distance
of his own early eighth
century BCE audience
from the epic past.
It dramatizes this historical
distance in the Phaeacians
who lie at an even greater removed,
so post-post-heroic as to be non-heroic.
Like many utopian fictions,
they may lie in an imagined future,
a readership of the poem
that is yet to come.
Entered Dido's Carthage.
If Scheria registers what it means
for the Odyssey to come after the Iliad
and its heroic world,
the Aeneid measures the
nearly thousand years
of human civilization
and in particular the rise of Rome
and of literature in Latin
that separates it from the archaic world
depicted in both Homeric epics.
It does so by presenting
the versions of Scheria
and the Carthage that
has just been founded
and which will be no more by Virgil's day.
I'm sorry, it does so by presenting
its version of Scheria in the Carthage
that has just been founded
and that will be no more
by Virgil's day.
History's defeated rival to Rome.
Carthage is nonetheless Rome's double.
The closest image in the poem
of the rich and sophisticated city
that the future Rome will be.
Both are non-Greek and a linguistic
as well as a historical
removed from Homer.
Dido and her urbane Carthaginians welcome
the Trojan remnants who
straggle to her shores,
the heroic world of Troy
but the Carthaginians
are not part of that world
and belong to a more civilized future.
They provide an enthralled audience
for Aeneas' narration
of the fall of his city
and subsequent wanderings
and so prefigure a modern
cultured readership
in Virgil's own Rome and beyond.
A Carthage model on Scheria
and the Phaeacians however,
already carried with it
unflattering connotations
from ancient critics of Homer.
From within Athens of
the late 4th century,
the reactionary Plato objected
to Odysseus' praise of the
pleasure and good fellowship,
the Euphrosyne of the Phaeacian banquets.
Odysseus says it's the
most beautiful of things.
He also objected to the
song of Ares and Aphrodite.
In particular,
in his attack on the immorality
of the Homeric poems of the
third book of the Republic.
Philip Hardy notes that defenders of Homer
had to allegorize the body's story
so that Venus and Mars would embody
the Empedoclean cosmogonic
principles of love and strife
as they do at the opening of
Lucretius' De Rerum Natura
and Virgil himself apparently refers
to this allegoresis of Venus and Mars
and the song of the nymph Clymene
in the fourth georgic.
Classical writers of Platonic
and Aristocratic leanings,
Pamela Gordon has shown
condemn the Phaeacians by identifying them
with vulgar, Epicureanism.
The pursuit of hedonistic pleasure.
The cryptic Phoenecian attributes
of the Phaeacians in the Odyssey itself
now belong in the Aeneid
to real Phoenicians.
The colonists who have
followed Dido from Tyre.
So it's with the people identified
with despised trade and double dealing
that Virgil links the associations
with Epicureanism, vulgar and real
that Gordon and other critics
have identified in the Carthage episode.
These include the city's opulence,
Dido's skepticism about the gods
who have ordered Aeneas to leave her.
Really the gods care about that she says.
And the sexual indulgence
which tempts the hero
to withdraw from his heroic mission.
Here too, a female leader marks
the merchant Carthaginians
with effeminacy.
In place of Demodocus, a song
about Ares and Aphrodite,
Dido's bard Yopus sings a cosmogonic song
about the movement of the stars,
the origins of men and beasts,
rain and lightning.
Yopus' song is a miniature
piece of natural science
and it pointedly excludes the gods.
Wealthy, materialess, godless
Carthage's disparaged twin
but has like Remus,
been obliterated by Rome
but which seems nonetheless to prefigure
and constitute one side of the metropolis
that Rome has become in Virgil's own day.
The city that Augustus was
transforming into marble.
As Aeneas watches Carthage going up,
he sees the foundations
being laid for a theater.
We are alerted immediately
to the drama of Dido
that will soon be played out in the poem
with its frequent imitations
and references to Greek tragedy
but the theater is also
a glaring anachronism
in the heroic world of the poem.
A further sign that Carthage stands
for a later stage of civilization.
Urbane, scientific, disenchanted.
A world of high culture,
capable of producing the Aeneid itself.
One would not expect to see a theater
in the backward and poor
Italy of the second half
of the poem.
There too, as in the conclusion
in the second part of the
Odyssey, the new Trojan War,
fought in the Italian
boondocks feels regressive
compared to Scheria-like Carthage.
This backward feeling is both
reinforced and complicated
by Virgil's separating out from Carthage,
the Hephaestus material
that Homer had joined to the Phaeacians
in the Odyssey and by his moving it
to the Italy of the poem's second half.
Gold may be everywhere in Carthage
but the divine goldsmith under his name,
of Vulcan, his Roman name
has taken up residence
off the coast of Italy
where in book eight he uses his skill,
not to make the luxury
appurtenances of a Phaeacia
or Carthage,
but to produce the weapons of Rome.
The episode of Vulcans
casting the shield of Aeneas
directly follows an Italian version
of Dido's earlier banquet
and its storytelling.
Evander has hosted Aeneas
at the religious festival
outside Pallantium and recounted to him
the story of Hercules and
the fire monster Cacus.
Where Dido's Carthaginians are rich
and listen to the post-epic,
and listen to post-epic natural
philosophy of Yopus' song,
Evander's Arcadians are poor
and his story of Hercules is pre-epic.
Part of a deeper mythological
past before the Trojan War.
Hercules fights primal, natural forces.
The contrast to just the
violent primitiveness of Italy,
Italian Cacus is in fact the half beast,
half god son of Vulcan,
Hephaestus himself.
And he makes a curious
double of the shield,
embodying Roman history
to which the lovemaking of
Vulcan and Venus now gives birth.
Vulcan not only returns to making armor
as he had done for Achilles in the Iliad,
he does so erotically enough,
at the behest of his wife
Venus, on behalf of Aeneas.
The offspring of another
of her adulterous affairs.
Venus seduces her husband
with evident allusions
to Demodocus' Phaeacian
song about Venus in Mars.
In addition, Vulcan
manufactures the thunderbolts
of Jupiter himself.
These constitute a conservative answer
to the science of a Lucretius or a Yopus
who sings about the natural
origins of rain and lightning
and with us dispels superstition
about divine thunder.
Placed in a firey cavern
beneath the Aeolian isles
next to Aeolia's prison of the winds,
described at the opening of the poem.
Vulcan's forge is a kind of underworld.
But it belongs to and predicts
no less than the britches and
sophistication of Carthage,
Rome's modern present
that Vulcan depicts on the
shield he makes for Aeneas.
The aegis under which the
hero will literally fight
in the second half of the home.
Hephaestian skill produces
the superior weapons,
themselves technological marvels
that will lead to Roman conquest.
By splitting the Phaeacian matter
of the Odyssey into
the respective episodes
of Carthage and Vulcan's forge,
the Aeneas projects two
versions of the future Rome.
They coexist as parts
of the same modern city,
out of the audience to
which the poem is addressed.
They encode different readerly attitudes
towards its own epic fiction
and towards the role of the poet himself.
Embodied in Vulcan's artifus.
The Carthaginian Phaeacian attitude,
materialist, scientifically enlightenment,
skeptical about the gods,
appears to supersede the heroic ethos
that Dido and her fellow
citizens enjoy hearing about
from Aeneas the storyteller.
Dido offers to Aeneas a
substitute for his martial labors
and a peaceable enjoyment of domesticity
and the wealth of a commercial people.
Through Vulcan, Virgil
may insert Rome's future
in the Aeneid's epic past
but he also recruits Aeneas,
an epic's hero of ethos
for the military industrial
complex of the Roman state.
For the interests of its aristocracy
and its new Augustan monarchy.
A project that requires the maintenance
of a religious establishment
and of religious fear itself.
The ambition and
sublimity of Virgil's epic
may need such a project as
much as the project needs it.
Otherwise, its Vulcan
might find himself reduced
to making toys for Eros as
Apollonius as Hephaestus does
in the Argonautica or
he makes a horse trough
for Callimachus.
But it is a Devil's bargain
as is the achievement of Rome itself.
The Aeneid evidently does put epic,
its archaic warrior heroism
and its old-fashioned religion
into the service of a modern war machine
and its pious warlords.
Insisting on their continuing
relevance for the present.
Warfare of today may be
infinitely more complex and global
but still war, it's more of the same.
It is a reading and an
attitude towards epic
that Virgil knowingly
transmits to his present
and beyond it.
And it may be for that reason
he wanted to burn the Aeneid.
His sympathies may lie
with the Carthaginian
Phaeacian sensibility
that the Aeneid censures for
its unbelief and effeminacy
and depicts under historical erasure,
overcome and obliterated
by Roman military success.
But that sensibility
persists inside the poem
to be recuperated,
in part in the poet's own day,
more fully perhaps by readers
in a future still to come.
Now like Virgil, Renaissance
poets inherited epic
after a long historical lapse.
They took up the classical
genre 1500 years later
in their own vernacular literary languages
and an age we shaped by
new mercantile capitalism,
new global and astronomical discoveries,
new technologies of
gunpowder and navigation,
new science and new secular attitudes
that accompanied all these developments.
Renaissance epic poets repeatedly stage
their modern distance from
the heroic world and ethos
that they depict by rewriting versions
of the Phaeacian
Carthaginian banquet scene.
As Virgil does in his
depiction of Carthage,
the Renaissance poet can take a critical,
even overtly hostile view
towards the modernity
of his own world,
materialistic and unheroic.
What may seem to prevent the
possibility of the heroic
in the poet's own present.
But the poet also, not so secretly,
registers an advance over the heroic past
that allows a hearing for other values.
Secular, scientific, peaceable.
Ariosto and Camoes
provide contrasting cases.
And Ariosto's Orlando Furioso
has the most elaborate
of these reworkings of
the Phaeacian episode
and therefore I can't really include it.
I'm going to have to just
briefly summarize it.
The paladin Ronaldo, I've
summarized it on the page
that I just put down there.
The paladin Ronaldo in the eight century
is hosted in Manchua and
given a banquet dinner
and then is given a ship
to take him down the Po.
And as he goes down the Po,
he comes to what is the
site of the future Ferrara
which where among other things,
an island in the Po which
had been turned into
a pleasure garden by the Este,
Ariosto's patrons and which is compared
and this is in your handout, to, Nausicaa
and Alcinous would not,
it's even better than
anything that they had
which is a tip-off to the
origins of the episode.
At the same time,
Ronaldo hears two stories of adultery
and about adulterous wives and husbands.
In both cases,
the wives are seduced
by riches into adultery.
Now the second case is the,
it is the wife of a judge.
So we've come down into the
sphere of the bourgeoisie.
She is seduced by a gold defecating dog
and he is in turn seduced by,
and gives up his own body
for a splendid palace.
The Mantuan setting allows Ariosto also
to praise the Duchess Isabella d'Este,
the sister of his Ferraraisai patrons
and other female rulers.
Versions of Arrate.
So this modern world contrasts,
is projected out of the eighth century
and it looks very much like
the modern Italian city-state.
It's morally compromised
as these stories of adultery suggest
and they're of course modeled on the Ares
and Aphrodite story originally.
But it has its advantages.
Splendid palaces filled
with Renaissance artwork
and patrons for the poet.
So if the Orlando Furioso
finally catches up
to this modern world at
its end, and this is the,
it is at the very end of the poem
I should've said as well.
The Lusiads of Camoes have been there
almost from the start and never leave it.
After the initial skirmish
between Vasco da Gama's crew
and the inhabitants of Mozambique,
almost all the ensuing
episodes of the poem
are versions of the stay of
Aeneas in Virgil's Carthage.
In Canto 2, Mercury
descends to warn da Gama
to flee away from Mombasa
as he had warned Aeneas
to leave Dido in the Aeneid.
The Portuguese make for Melendi
where their ambassador first echoes
Virgil's Ilioneus to Dido
and then invokes the example
of the hospitality of Alcinous.
The Melendian king is
a Dido Alcinous figure
who welcomes the Portuguese
and listens to da Gama
for the next three Cantos
tell narratives about
Portuguese heroism in the past
and about its national wars
against Islam and Spain
and then about his own
relatively uneventful voyage.
The storm of book six
drives da Gama to Calicut
much as the storm of
book one of the Aeneid
drives Aeneas to Carthage and Calicut too,
turns out to be a Carthage
from which the hero must escape
to the warning of the
North African Moor Mansaide
who is privy to the plots
of the Muslim traders
against the Portuguese.
Mansaide that is,
plays the role of Mercury
admonishing Aeneas
to leave Dido's city.
The island of love of the last two Cantos
is introduced to us as
still another Carthage.
Venus had once invoked such
a device, the poet declares
to greet Anchises' son
Aeneas in that meadow
where Dido's subtlety bought
Carthage with a bull's hide.
The Portuguese enjoy a sexual
interlude there in book nine
where they join all other,
where they join all other
lovers including adulteresses
who are ensnared in Vulcan's net.
In the last, 10th Canto
they are entertained
by a siren who sings of things not known
to Yocus of Carthage,
nor to Demodocus among the Phaeacians.
First a prophecy of future Portuguese wars
and victories in Asia.
This is the Demodocus part.
Then as her place is taken by Tethus,
a Yocus-like lesson in
cosmography which uses, as a prop,
a scale model of the universe
enclosed in a crystal sphere
based on a similar
sphere made by Archimedes
and celebrated by Cicero
and the poet Claudian.
Camoes conveniently labels
all of these episodes
for the reader to make sure that we know
where we are in the epic tradition
and it seems that we never leave Carthage
although poem alternates between
bad, inhospitable Carthages
that will be destroyed
and good, hospital ones.
The Lusiadas thus plays almost
all of its narrative present
in one or other of these
versions of Carthage, Scheria.
The locus of unheroic modernity.
And these appear to crowd
conventional martial action
into the past and practically
out of da Gama's mission
which is at once a failed event
to set up a trading pact in Calicut
and a successful voyage of reconnaissance.
He charts out the sea route to India,
knowing that the Portuguese
will return with their warships
and establish an Indian Ocean Empire.
For it is the Portuguese,
instead of their various
hosts who are the true moderns
of the poem which recounts events
that were only two generations removed
when Camoes began writing about them.
They have guns and at Melinde
they give a demonstration
as a supposed celebration
and salute to the Sultan.
It was like the Cyclopes at the Smithy
as the firebombs were exploded.
These are the new thunderbolts
from Vulcan's forge
that make ancient warfare obsolete
as the arms made by Vulcan in the Aeneid
had themselves represented
the modern weaponry
that would build Rome's Imperial might
and would relegate Homeric warfare
to a distant, heroic past.
So Portugal, the poet
announces will be a new Rome
but on a much larger, global scale.
But Portugal's empire
will be an empire of trade
and this Rome itself made
the war like a Carthage.
The Portuguese possessed
the maritime technology
and skills of navigation that
make them the new Phaeacians,
Phoenicians with magic ships
capable of reaching all destinations.
Camoes celebrates a Portugal
that has transformed the globe into
a large commercial network
where beneath the superficial differences,
all ports of call are the same.
A Carthage that is
everywhere, starting at home.
The closing stanzas, 99.
I'm sorry, of book eight of The Lusiads
draw on Ariosto's language
in Canto 43 of The Furioso.
To invey in their own turn
against modern greed and corruption
but where Ariosto sees
his own moneyed world
as possibly saner and more peaceable
than the heroic world of his poem,
the soldier Camoes wonders
if his vocation is gone.
Heroism emptied out or
tainted by mercenary aims
in Portugal's great imperial venture.
Beneath the poem's notorious
double time scheme.
Sorry, not double time scheme.
Beneath the poem's notorious
double divine machinery
of a Christian God to whom da Gama prays
and of classical gods who respond,
lies a disenchanted world
of all too human motivation.
Muslim traders bribe The Catual,
the Minister of Calicut to prevent da Gama
from leaving Calicut and
to scuttles his mission.
Da Gama's main Aeneas-like
act in the poem,
Michael Merne and Timothy
Hampton have shown
is simply to extricate
himself out of this Carthage
in the nick of time.
An Arab fleet from Mecca,
armed with cannonry of their own,
Vulcan's thunderbolts
as the poem calls them,
is due to arrive on the scene.
But da Gama has really no place to go
except to another Carthage.
He and his poet are trapped
in their own modernity.
So Tasso's version of the
Phaeacian Carthaginian banquet
in the Gerusalemme liberata occurs
in the episode of the
Magus or Sage of Ascalon
who alerted by Peter the Hermit,
invites the Crusaders, Carlo and Ubaldo
into his underground dwelling in Canto 14.
The basic shape of the
topos can be discerned.
The magus offers them a meal
in his splendid palace which is a product
of untold wealth and a
locus of natural philosophy.
And in inset narration,
he recounts to them the
story of Armida and Rinaldo.
The next morning he
sends them on their way
to rescue Rinaldo on the
marvelous ship of Fortune
which is a version of the
Phaeacians' magical ships.
But the pattern is complicated
by Tasso's further modeling of the episode
of the descent beneath the earth
of Vergil's Aristaeus
and the fourth Georgic
on a more recent invitation
of that Vergillian episode
and Fracastoro's short
scientific epic, Syphilis.
The magus lives, sorry.
The magus lives in a realm
at the source of rivers
and lower down, of living silver, mercury
and sparkling gemstones
that fills its cavern
with artificial light.
No practitioner of black magic,
he is a kind of natural scientist
who splits his time between
the subterranean palace
and an observatory on Mount
Carmel where he watches
Venus and Mars without any vale.
As well as the slow or rapid orbits
of the heavenly bodies.
He looks down on the
generation of the rain in dew
and upon how lightning is
kindled and strikes the earth.
The science of the magus can be linked
to Epicurean attitudes
and it is he who recounts,
to be sure,
with disapproval the song
of Armida's artificial siren
who advises Rinaldo to enjoy his body.
Let him care nothing if the
heavens thunder or lightning.
Let it menace and kindle
bolts as much as it likes.
Such thunder and lightning,
an Epicurean would explain
has nothing to do with the gods.
The meal and the sumptuous
underground palace
of the magus recalls the
banquets of Carthage and Scheria.
His establishment in the womb of the earth
is a scientific version mediated
through Fracastoro's poem
of the very treasure vaults found
in previous Italian heroic poems.
Riches, science and
technology come together
in this projection of modernity,
apparently far from the 11th century world
of the First Crusade.
So does the spectra of
a godless materialism
that Tasso tries to put to rest.
The magus was born a pagan,
thought he knew all that there was to know
about the workings of nature,
but then he met Peter
the Hermit who converted
and baptized him.
He is another man in parte
than the one he used to be.
I'd watch out for that
because that's what
Petrarch says about himself.
The opening of the Canzoniere.
I'm another man in parte
for what I used to be.
And it's the magus, suitably enough,
given his realm of metals,
who will play Vulcan and provide Rinaldo
with the epic shield on
which his Este ancestors
are depicted.
(speaks foreign language)
For the blood of the
Este, glorious and aghast,
the order was seen without interruption.
By fortunate puns, Actium and Augustus,
viewed as the climax
of Virgil's description
of the Shield of Aeneas begin the ecresus
of Rinaldo's shield.
If the epics like the
models of Homer's Scheria
and Virgil's Carthage affords a glimpse
of a seemingly post-epic
scientific modernity
of a literally earthly wealth
and Epicurean unbelief,
it seeks preemptively
to recruit that future
for the conservative, religious
and heroic aims of Tasso's poem.
But it may succeed in doing so,
like the conversion of the
magus himself, only in part.
Now by contrast, Spenser's cave of Mammon
in book two of canto
seven of The Faerie Queene
reduces this future to a
bourgeois world of money
and in doing so, he demonizes
the Scheria Carthage episode.
Drawing on the same sources
as Tasso's episode of the magus
and on the episode itself,
Spenser first places the
underground treasure cave of Mammon
next door to Pluto's hell,
activating the similarity
of names, excuse me,
of Pluto and Plutus, the god of wealth.
And then shows it leading into hell itself
in the Garden of Proserpina
and the adjoining River Causidus.
Covered with smoke and soot,
Mammon first appears to quote,
"Have been seared in the
smith's fire-spitting forge."
And his realm contains a forge.
Its furnaces and bellows manned by fiends.
Spenser associates its fires,
difficult to distinguish from hellfire
with Vulcan and earlier,
under his other Virgilian
name with Mulciber.
This smithy does not seem to produce
any Hephaestian artwork or weaponry.
Just the precious metals themselves
with which the money
god earlier points out,
Guyon might buy shields, steeds and arms
as well as crowns and kingdoms
but it may have produced
a Hephaestian automata
in the allegorical figure of disdain.
A giant made of gold and 1590,
The Faerie Queene of iron
in its 1596 version.
Who dogs Guyon's steps, ready
to snatch and destroy him.
Guyon replies that he
would rather gain kingdoms
the old fashioned way, by
the brute force of arms
and in an appointed aristocratic threat
against this capitalist upstart
asserts that he would quote,
be lured of those that riches have
than them to have myself
and be their servile slave.
Mammon looks like a member
of the Fugger family
and merchant.
Fugger banking and merchant family
who monopolized mining
and trade in metals.
Mammon represents the
new world of capitalism
and its urban middle class.
He leads Guyon into a throne room
that is long and wide as its sum yield
or solemn temple were.
That is the haunt of
guildsmen and of lawyers.
The latter like Ariosto's judge.
On the throne is his daughter Philotime,
the lover of honor who fuels ambition
and is a kind of alternative ego.
Sorry, excuse me.
Is a kind of alternative
or allegorical alter ego
of Queen Elizabeth.
The bourgeoisie claims
its own independent realm
within the heroic realm of the poem.
The episode reveals its links
to the Phaeacian Carthage
model at the level of plot
when Mammon, like Alcinous,
offers his daughter in
marriage to the visiting hero.
Guyon turns him down with a politeness
that's bordering on sarcasm.
It would be too great a
theologically colored grace
conferred on him he says,
when of course it would
be he, the gentleman,
who would confer honor on the
moneyed citizen's daughter
he might marry.
Perhaps the honor her
name says she craves.
So many Elizabethan gentlemen did,
replenishing their own family
fortunes in the process.
Nor will Guyon eat the
proffered golden fruit,
nor sit down on Mammon's sliver stool.
There is not going to be any Phaeacian
or Carthaginian banquet in this episode.
Guyon just says no to
all these temptations
of Spenser's present
and signals the poem's
aristocratic disdain
for the new money of the city
better than any allegorical giant.
But Mammon spells out
the times have changed.
How that does live in later times
must wage thy works for wealth
and life for gold engage.
He is the capitalist
future that is already here
and that threatens to
relegate the heroic world
of Faerieland to the past.
From Mammon's point of view,
perspective already available
to Spenser's first and later readers,
these cracks in epic's aristocratic
facade are easier to see
and I simply can't really resist this.
Spenser wickedly parodies
Guyon's intentious disdain
for Mammon's riches and
reduces it to braggadocio.
In the world of Braggadocio himself.
In the ensuing well
back of Hellenore Fablio
of books three, nine and ten.
When Malbecco, miser and doublet of Mammon
offers the imposter knight money
in order to enlist him in the recovery
of his runaway wife,
Hellenore, Braggadocio replies.
"I loathe as dung, Nadine my due reward.
"Fame is my need and glory, virtuous pray.
"But minds of mortal men are much marred
"and moved amidst with nasty
mucks and neat regard."
The over the top alliteration
of the final couplet
gives the game away and
lowers still further,
the low comedy of the episode.
Braggadocio goes on to
steal Malbecco's gold
as Paridell has stolen and abandoned
Malbecco's wife Hellenore
and these false knights
just might disclose the
true nature of knighthood.
The episode further rewrites
the earlier Mammon
allegory to another version
of the Phaeacian Carthaginian banquet.
The meal that the unwilling host Malbecco
is forced to offer the wandering knights
who otherwise threaten
to burn down his castle.
And at which Paridell and Britomart
each recount their Trojan genealogies
in the manner of the
guests Odysseus and Aeneas.
Eventually Hellenore herself
sets Malbecco's house
in riches of fire like
another burning Troy,
as Spenser offers a debased version
of the epic myth of Troy.
In a May December story of adultery
out of Chaucer's Merchant's Tale
and Gascoigne's The Adventures of F.J.,
novellas like the ones told
at the end of the Orlando Furioso.
Or he reduces that myth, the Trojan myth
as the Phaeacian bard
Demodocus does in The Odyssey.
To the adultery of an
Aphrodite and an Ares
at the expense of a gold
handling smith Hephaestus
with little of the Olympian
Phaeacian sophistication
and good cheer.
Instead, Spenser risks
having the national dynastic
project Troy-novant,
Gloriana, The Faerie Queene.
The epicness of his poem swallowed up
into the moneyed modern world
and its lower literary genres.
Malbecco turns into jealousy,
the ethos particular to the novel.
Hellenore, Helen-or ends
up among the satyrs.
That is in satire.
Milton's Eden is the
Scheria of Paradise Lost
while Pandemonium is the poem's
malsabarian Vulcanian Rome.
Paradise Lost starts at
the beginning of time
and treats events that
shape us as human beings.
It cannot but look forward, Hegel notes,
in order to disqualify
Paradise Lost as an epic.
He says, "In Milton, we always
find feeling in consideration
"drawn from a modern imagination,
"the moral ideas of his day."
This modernity takes two forms.
Utopian and the Scheria-like Eden
which is not primitive enough for Hegel,
demonic in Satan's Hephaestian
capital and seat of monarchy.
And once, too atavistic and
all too actual for Milton.
Milton gives us the
epic coordinates of Eden
in the menu that Eve gathers together
for the couple's first dinner party
in honor of the Angel Raphael,
the poem's version of the epic banquet.
Whatever earth, all-bearing
mother yields in India,
east or west or middle shore in Pontus
or the Punic Coast or
where Alcinous reigned,
fruit of all kinds.
The whole globe has contracted into Eden
which buoys between east and west,
takes on the milieu of Mediterranean epic.
Of Pontic, Colchis of the
Argonautica of Valerius Flaccus
of Punic Carthage and of
Scheria, the realm of Alcinous.
The foodstuffs announce the familiar topas
of the hospitable meal
accompanied by storytelling.
What follows Raphael's too long narrations
of the war in heaven
and the creation of God's new universe
correspond to the songs
of Demodocus and Yopus,
told here in a reversal of epic convention
by the guest rather than the host.
The Phaeacian model remains
in place in the poem.
Satan's subsequent approach
to Eve harkens back
to Odysseus' first
encounter with Nausicaa.
It casts Scheria itself as
a place of idenic innocence.
Pious though they are,
Adam and Eve lived the Epicurean good life
of the Phaeacians.
UnwarliKe,
looking forward to the nightly lovemaking
that caps their existence.
Then listen with fascination
to Raphael's narration
of the war in heaven that
casts such epic heroism
into a quaint literary
past made ridiculous
by Satan's invention of artillery.
Yes artillery was there
from the beginning,
at least from the second
day of the heavenly battle
to ruin the individual heroics of epic.
Eden is also a realm of
scientific enlightenment
where Adam and Raphael can engage
in astronomical observation,
much like Tasso's Magus.
Yopus is here too.
Adam and Eve thus live
not only at the beginning
of human existence
but in a post-futile, post-epic age.
As Fredric Jameson boldly
and brilliantly puts it,
"Alongside the futile
world of God and His court,
"of Satan and his host,
"Adam is clearly of another
species, the commoner.
"The first bourgeois.
"That extraordinary mutation
which is middle class man,
"destined as we know today to be fruitful
"and to multiply and
to inherit the earth."
Unquote.
Struggle with quoting Jameson is the,
what surrounds it does not seem so good.
Satan first enters Eden
in simile as a thief,
then to unhoard the cash
of some rich burger.
Eden, like other epic versions
of Phaeacian Scheria
is a utopian projection
of a modern world
that has superseded
epic's own heroic realm.
The realm of war.
It is Milton's dream of
a virtuous bourgeoisie,
a bourgeoisie still unfallen
and thus not yet subject
to the sardonic tinge
of Jameson's description.
In a significant revision of his models,
Milton makes this Phaeacian Eden
not the region of unbelief
but of true individual faith.
The more so when it becomes after the fall
of spiritual paradise within
as opposed to the worldly
religion of the state
and its enforcers of conscience.
For at the same time that
God makes another heaven
for these new creatures,
Satan and his followers,
Mammon and Mulciber
make their own imitation of heaven
in their infernal capital
city of Pandemonium.
They do so slightly after
God has made the new Eden
and theirs too is a version of modernity.
The first prototype of the seats of rising
and falling empires that
waltzed through the globe,
cataloged in book 11.
Borrowed from Spenser,
Miton's fallen angel Mammon mines gold
from the bowels of hell.
Mulciber's Hephaestus,
Mulciber, Mulphaestus sorry.
Formerly the architect in heaven
works the metal into molds
and builds the palace.
Pandemonium resembles both Dido's Carthage
and its wealth and
built in a day as it is,
the military Rome that was
Carthage's mortal enemy.
The conflation suggests the devils
are their own worst enemies
and that this seat of empire
too is doomed to fail.
Such capital cities, Hugh
Trevor-Roper has argued,
by the unsustainable consumption
of their royal courts
and by the expense of their
military establishments
had doomed the mercantile city states
which had been the
cradle of the Renaissance
and its humanism and
led to the revolutions
of the mid 17th century.
The English Revolution
most memorable among them.
In fact, as shown in the
debate in the infernal Council
in book one, Mammon, the representative
of the city bourgeoisie,
hater of royal pomp
and advocate of peace would
like to be left alone to quote,
live to ourselves.
Though in this vast recess,
free and to none accountable.
However, Hawksby points
out that Mammon represents
a double of the middle class Adam,
but a godless demonic
one and he is swept up,
willing or not.
Not only into the building of pandemonium
but into Satan's project
of war and imperialism.
Mulciber reappears in
the visions of the future
that Michael bestows on Adam,
themselves modeled on
Vulcan's shield of Aeneas
in the Aeneid and Hephaestus'
shield of Achilles
in the Iliad.
In the third vision,
the unnamed Tubalcain whose
name was traditionally seen
to be a variant of Vulcain
invents metalworking.
The daughters of this race of Cain
will seduce the children of Seth,
hitherto peaceable and free.
Quote, "In the amorous net, fast-caught,
"they liked and each his liking chose."
Unquote.
As Milton blends the myth of Pandora,
originally an automaton
created by Hephaestus Vulcan,
with the other Hephaestian
story of Ares and Aphrodite.
The offspring of these ill-mated marriages
will be the warrior giants,
the first epic heroes
and empirical conquerors
in human history and the once godly,
now made Mammons will
fight at possible quote,
"To live secure, worldly or dissolute
"on what their Lord shall
leave them to enjoy."
Unquote.
Paradise Lost offers two
versions of the bourgeois future.
One, Phaeacian and utopian
that appears to supersede
the royal aristocratic order
and its epic fictions
and one in which that
regressive warrior order
keeps returning as it had in
the restoration in England
and at which a moneyed
middle class finds itself
as the beneficiary and silent accomplice
of a satanic military
industrial establishment.
In the second version, epic
and its glorification of war
never dies away, however
much Paradise Lost
may claim to end the genre.
We can ask which of
these futures is our own
and let me just conclude.
We can pose this question here
and in other epics I have discussed
because the epic world is not quote,
"An entirely finished thing,
"not only as an authentic
event of the distant past
"but also on its own terms
and by its own standards."
Unquote.
It is not quote,
"Impossible to change,
to rethink or reevaluate
"anything in it."
Unquote.
These words are Bakhtin's
and they're a doubling down on
Hegel that is influenced too
by Lukacs' notion of the
roundedness of the epic
that is the Homeric world.
Unlike Lukacs and Hegel,
Bakhtin does not romanticize
this epic world as a place
where one could be at home everywhere.
The land of unified consciousness.
There is nothing living
about this world at all
and more than the Odyssey does
in the underworld of book 11,
Bakhtin consigns the genre to a past
that is not only absolute but dead.
Bakhtin broadly assimilates in epic,
the other high genres
of classical antiquity
and the Middle Ages.
All of them to be made
obsolete by the novel.
His claim is transparently false
as if any work of literature
could wall itself off
from its readers and quote,
"Not commit an individual
point of view or evaluation."
Unquote.
It's based on a mistaken
conception, excuse me.
Of the, excuse me.
It is based on a mistaken conception
of the suppression of the
heroic that we've built in,
we've seen epic built into its fictions.
"Both Stinger and the listener,
"imminent in the epic
genre," Bakhtin writes,
"are located at the same time
"and on the same evaluative plane
"but the represented
world of the hero stands
"on an ultimately
different and inaccessible
"time and value plane
separated by epic distance.
"The space between them is
filled with national tradition."
Unquote.
Such tradition we are asked
to believe freezes the meaning
of the epic world
and the deeds done within
it as something sacrosanct,
beyond criticism and evaluation.
But tradition does not
do anything of the sort.
Sacred books and just as much,
perhaps even more than great literature
which sometimes acquires something
of the aura of the
sacred are reinterpreted,
argued over, reattached to the present
precisely because they have
something at stake in them.
If one wishes to grant him
the benefit of the doubt,
and I'm not so inclined.
Bakhtin may be isolating
a particularly reverential
mode of reading conservative,
of reading sorry.
That is conservative and
class-bound in nature
versus the more open, democratic ethos
that he ascribes to the novel.
But epic from its Homeric beginnings
has figured a post-heroic
audience inside the poems.
In dialogue with the heroes themselves,
opening up a portal to the future.
Starting with Virgil and taken up
by the Renaissance epic poets,
these moments of contact
with a more modern future,
especially with more modern readers
measure the, excuse me.
Measure the lateness of the poem
to the tradition of the genre
and to its celebration of martial prowess.
In all of these cases I have suggested,
this modernity is linked to
material wealth and technology.
To alternative ways of
producing human prosperity
that do not depend or do not
seem to depend on warfare.
This modernity looks
back into the epic world
and asks awkward questions
about the purposes of heroism itself.
About the greed that is taken for granted
by a belligerent, feudal society.
At the same time proposes enlightened,
scientific attitudes that question
the religious props of that society.
Through its glimpses into a
future dwelling side by side
with the present of the world of heroes,
epic, far from being sacrosanct depicts
its own desacralization.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Ayesha] David would
you take your questions?
- Sure.
- Or would you like
one of us to moderate?
- No, I'm happy to take questions.
- [Ayesha] Questions, go to mics.
There must be questions.
- [Man] Ah, can you hear me?
I'd like to hear a bit
more about how it works
in the Iliad.
This sort of crashing of the
two versions stuck in the past.
Are there places there to be examined?
I'm thinking here mostly of so much
of what Virgil does in these,
the later epic writers.
It's so, so much of that
is from the Odyssey.
The world of ships and trade.
And there are so many
banquets in the Odyssey
and I'm wondering how.
I was especially
wondering whether you got,
couldn't work Menelaus'
banquet in there in Sparta.
Especially since it has
a kind of big mercantile
theme there as well.
Where you have a case
of a traditional hero,
like a warrior who somehow
seems to have upgraded
to a tradesman, so.
- Okay,
so we're talking about the
Odyssey and not the Iliad?
You said, the okay.
- But I do have
the Iliad question.
- Okay.
- It's kind of lurking
in the background as well.
- Okay, well yeah I think that.
I think it's Elian who says that both,
that Menelaus and Odysseus
look like merchants
who were going from place to
place, accumulating goods.
So there is some sense
in which Menelaus is,
I mean Menelaus is Apollos and which is,
which he says, "Well maybe
I'm the richest man on earth.
"Maybe I'm not, but you know it's."
He's quite satisfied with himself.
There is a relationship
between that passage surely
and the Phaeacians in Scheria, yeah.
It is, we already have
some sense that this is,
that the world to which people
are returning is just not a,
it's not as heroic a world.
Something happened in those 10 years
where Menelaus has been
getting all of his riches.
- [Man] And I guess part of my question
was also the way that
crashes Egypt together with,
well in Virgil's, in Virgil's Carthage
you have a kind of crash
of Egypt with Phoenicia
and so those two banquets coming together
in Carthage would be a nice, a nice thing.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
I mean the, go.
- Thank you so much.
I just have a question about, sorry yeah.
I just have a question
about your interpretation
of Odysseus' reception of Demodocus' song.
You mentioned this relationship between
the killing of the suitors and the capture
of Ares and Aphrodite
and on the one hand, yes.
It does seem like a contrast between
this more primitive reaction
and the use of artisan
manufactured bondage
and also the use of social bonds legally.
On the other hand,
I think Marine Alden argues
this in a 2017 article.
It seems as though Odysseus
in the audience of Demodocus'
song might be seeing
that Hephaestus gets laughed
at by the other gods,
might be seeing that there's no mention
that he receives a financial recompense
and we conclude the song
just looking at Aphrodite taking a bath.
Like the gods who are looking at her
getting caught in the net
and so I'm just wondering
if even on the level
of the internal audience,
Odysseus himself,
there's a way in which
this portrait of modernity
is pushing Odysseus back,
posing a warning that
legal bonds aren't enough
and he has to kill the suitors to preserve
any sense of dignity.
- Well I, the poem clearly takes the,
is on the side of Odysseus.
So when he comes back and kills everybody,
the poem is on his side.
However, one can ask oneself
whether the story of Ares and Aphrodite
does not offer a different way
that these things could
happen and that you know,
you know if you decide that
you wanted to absolutely,
that you have to kill people
and use violence at the end,
then you can make these
objections to the story and say,
well does, how well does
Hephaestus really come out
at the end of this?
But there does seem to
be some sense that okay,
what more did you expect
from Aphrodite anyway?
And that, but also it's
a comic song for it.
For the Phaeacians.
Whatever it is for Odysseus
may be something else
but as far as the
Phaeacians are concerned,
I think that they,
they're laughing along with the gods
and they're laughing along, you know,
the dirty joke of Hermes and Apollo.
Hermes says, "Hey, tie me up, tie me up.
"You know as long as you
tie me up with Aphrodite,
"I'm fine."
And I think we're supposed to feel
that that's their kind of song
as opposed to the two epic things
that are on either side of it.
But that's, that's my line.
I guess.
But it's a great question and it's also,
I mean you're right.
The poem, the poem finally
takes the side of Odysseus.
That's not.
- [Woman] Hello, thank you
this is really interesting
even though I had to
come in slightly late.
But I was wondering if
you were going to extend
what you're doing beyond Milton,
if there was another epic beyond that
that you would like to fit in
to what you've been talking about.
- I mean I think alas,
that Milton really does
slightly close the tradition.
There is Lucrezia Marinella's
terrible poem the "Enrico".
Which is, it's actually pre-Milton.
Does have an interesting moment
where of a character named Cercina.
So little Cerci who is a
kind of natural scientist
and where some of these same
topoi are being redeployed
and you know, but it's a
kind of footnote I think.
I'm not really sure where
one goes after Milton.
We really do get the novel
and I'm not sure that there's,
that this particular topos.
- Yeah.
- That I can trace much beyond it.
- [Woman] I mean I haven't
looked into it in any depth
but I was thinking of Omeros
by Derek Walcott perhaps?
- Well yeah, I mean there is not.
I don't think we have.
I mean, I like Omeros.
I don't think that there
is a scene that gives us
this kind of correspondence.
- Yeah, yeah, okay.
- I mean certainly Omeros
is a meditation on,
particularly on the
relationship of novel and epic
and about what happens in a modern,
the modern commercial world
and whether there is any real epic left.
That certainly is part
of its pathos I think.
- [Woman] Yeah okay, thank you.
- Chris.
- [Chris] I know as in a courtroom,
you're never supposed to ask a question
you don't know the answer to
and I really don't know the answer to this
but I'm gonna ask it anyway.
What does Veggio's 13th book do
to the Aeneid as an act of reception
in your terms?
Is it fun to think about?
- Okay, well I mean,
one of the things,
clearly part of what that
book's trying to do is to dispel
the idea that the Aeneid closes as it does
with a brutal act of violence and revenge
but rather ends with
marriage and a kind of,
a kind of happy futurity.
What it does, it also,
it may say something
about Veggio's own time.
Wanting, I'm not sure I can
speculate much further than that
but it's clearly, it's part of.
Its sense of wanting to
get Virgil off the hook
in some ways is part of
what it's responding to.
But it's also,
and it's also trying to normal.
It's trying to is yeah,
this is what a comic poem at the end.
It's to take the, one way to look at it
is to take the Odyssean structure
of the second part of the Aeneid which,
and to say yes it really
is all about returning home
and getting, and unifying.
Not reuniting but finding a wife.
And that that,
I mean that is after all
part of what is happening
in the second part of the poem.
And here it just, it's simply.
Let's take the happy sequel.
I mean one could think about, anyway.
I'm trying to, what's
the novel that's based on
Lavinia's point of view?
But it is that.
- Lavinia.
- Yeah, Lavinia.
It's something like that,
of trying to make the
Aeneid more palatable
for the schoolboy audiences
to whom one assumes.
- [Chris] But not to modernize it.
- Well it does, I guess.
I mean yeah, I.
I don't remember it quite well enough
to be able to give you the answer.
You know.
- [Man] Sorry.
- [Man] David, I was
thinking of Epic and Empire
quite a lot as I was sitting here
because I used to teach in the course,
I think it's now called English 130
that used to be called English 129
and read Epic and Empire to
help me understand the books
and I guess many of the
themes from Epic and Empire
sort of underlie what you said today
but I wonder if looking back you know,
is there anything you
think differently about
than when you wrote that?
Or has this cast any new light
on the work you did then?
- Well thank you for that.
Because I mean yeah,
what I might have said in
my introductory remarks
to this already overly long lecture.
Was that this is, it is a kind of rethink.
I mean it's trying to look at epic
from a slightly different
point of view than epic,
than the essay that begins Epic and Empire
which was again one of
these big overview essays.
And where I mean I do think,
I mean epic is clearly, it
celebrates a martial ethos
and a particular class ethos
but that already, from its very beginnings
it is telling you that there
are other possibilities
and it projects.
My, what interests me
is this projection to a better,
a different future and maybe
a better future which I think,
which has among other things.
Women are in charge.
I mean therefore it's totally utopian.
That it is, that it's materially
and technologically much advanced
and much more comfortable
and much less given to war.
And I think that,
one of the things that interests me
about the way that Milton
may close this tradition
is that there is a certain
despair about this.
He gives you two different versions
but basically seem to be
living under the satanic regime
and not under the idenic one.
- [Man] Good, thanks David.
- [Woman] Thanks so much David.
- Yeah.
- This was just such a joy.
And maybe I'm just bringing out
what was implicit in the talk
and what I've found so delightful
but the idea that epic has encoded in it
tropologically sort of
scenes of its own reception
and I guess I'm wondering and again,
gonna do the thing where I ask a question
to which I don't know the answer.
So much of this seems like
a literary history of epic
in that you know,
are these scenes of reading
in particular or you know,
how do you account for this
originating in an oral form?
What would?
I mean perhaps that
actually makes more sense
at the scene of hospitality
being the kind of primary
scene of reception but.
- Thank you Cathy.
Yeah I mean, the.
We assume that the Homeric poems
were recited at events very much
like the banquet in Scheria.
You have a banquet and the
famously opening of book nine.
This is what Plato hated.
Odysseus says, "The best of things,
"the very best of things
is when people all sit here
"and are eating and feasting
and listening to poetry."
And so it is giving us,
it is clearly a scene of reception
that's already there in the archaic world.
By the time we get to Virgil,
I mean we are probably
people are listening
to epic in very much the same way.
That they're probably, these are.
It's being recited
orally probably to people
and maybe after dinner.
And, but it is this.
We are sort of seeing,
and I think this continues all the way.
All the way through Paradise Lost,
that these, that Raphael,
Raphael's telling his narrations.
That this is one of the
ways in which poetry,
this long oral tradition is still there
because when we talk about,
people read things aloud in the,
up until audiobooks.
But the nights,
one way to understand things like
these interminable 17th century novels
and very long 19th century
novels is that you know,
every night after dinner,
people are gathered together
and somebody's sitting there reading.
And that this is very much a
part of what sociability was.
They didn't have television.
So this is one of the
ways in which these novels
are being produced.
What interests me is the notion.
I mean clearly this talk
has said that is that this,
it's always.
The audience is projected
as being a future.
It's a posterity, it's a future audience
that's being imagined.
And also one that basically is
at considerable distance from
this, from the world of the epic.
The epic can imagine people
who don't really share
some of its heroes values and right there.
I, the.
I guess the corresponding
moment in the Iliad
is when we find Achilles singing
the feats of heroes in his tent.
That this is,
that's how this stuff
is being transmitted.
That's all.
Yes.
- Maybe I'll take us
to the final question.
David, I want to ask you to maybe reflect
about what is the consequence for
a kind of longer literary
history of the talk you just gave
because in part, what
you are talking about
is a kind of dialectical relationship
between a mercantile,
commercial world of the modern
and thinking of Octavius
and in Shakespeare's
"Antony and Cleopatra",
the universal landlord
versus the epic boss
to which is Antony who
will be defeated at Actium
and I wonder if there's something about
the dialectical nature of these in epic,
the way in which epic
opens these wormholes
that might make us think or rethink
the kind of Bakhtinian
and Lukacsian difference
between epic and novel.
To think about at what
points does the novel,
perhaps into the 19th and
20th century, even now.
In its engagement with this dialectic,
with this presentation of
the kind of future tense
that is also retrospective is returning us
to some of the kind of intellectual
work that epic is doing
and the kind of cultural
place that epic has.
Even if it's abandoning the
specific tropoligcal tracing
that you did in this talk.
- Well that's, I mean it's a huge question
to which I'm not sure I can give
a particularly satisfactory
answer but what I am trying.
Yeah, I mean part of what
I'm clearly trying to say,
that is, that.
The Bakhtinian model
is that the novel swallows up all genres.
The Morettian model is that the
epic swallows up all genres.
And that it's already,
that and one way to see this is that the,
that we already have
novellas in some ways,
included within,
preview with Renaissance epic but even,
let's take the Ares and Aphrodite episode.
Just that there are generic mixings
that are already there in epic.
Yes, I think that
the, the question of where
does the mercantile world fit
into, next.
It is literally adjacent in the Odyssey
to the world of the heroes.
In the second part of the Odyssey,
the stories of Phoenician traders are,
and also of cretins who
are also seafaring people
are all over the place and they you know,
Odysseus makes up stories in which
he is interacting with the
Phoenicians, with cretins.
He is and,
we recognize that there
is this whole other world
of trade and commerce
that's, that's sitting there.
But which is,
which is not being enobled
through warfare and that is,
that that seems to be what.
I mean it is a dialectic
that's there from the beginning
and if we want to say
that that is part of what,
the work of the novel as a,
particularly as a bourgeois form
is that perhaps it does
reverse these things.
Part of the problem also with Bakhtin
just to spell it out is that when Bakhtin
tries to talk about the novel,
partly because of his own,
his own political situation, whatever.
He wants to talk about the novel
as being something that
comes from the folk
from down below and the
novel's a bourgeois form
and that's,
I mean Lukacs actually
has no problems with this.
But it is, it's a bourgeois form
and therefore it is trying to justify
the existence of a class that
is not aristocratic and noble.
Even though many of its protagonists
will still be from the old aristocracy.
So I'm not, I'm rambling
at this point but I am.
But I think that one way to look at this
is the same kind of reversal that epic
is still looking at
things, to a certain extent
from the side of the
dominant martial ethos.
And that up to Milton, where there's this.
Where the reversal really does take place
and that the novel tends to,
tends to follow Milton
in wishing to find a virtuous bourgeoisie.
Yeah.
- Thank you so much David.
I mean speaking of the dialectic,
I was thinking that maybe Lukacs' point
is not even so much a distinction between
a roundedness of the epics
and something else in the novel.
That on the contrary,
one could say nothing is more obsessed
with another version of roundedness
than the totality than
the novel for Lukacs.
It seems rather than whatever
we really had to sing about,
the epics.
His idea was that the
epic had a ground beyond
or before itself.
What is really epic for him
is not so much the epics
but the epic world.
The world in which
the epic originates.
- Yep.
- As the epic and the
novel as that totality
which doesn't have an epic world.
- Yeah though I.
- And just one last point
of those.
I mean Lukacs wrote his piece as a preface
to a book he has never written
on Dostoevsky and he was,
his idea was a return of the,
of kind of an epic
constellation in modernity.
So my question would be,
do we just think that
this brings something
to the possibility of a
literary history of the epics?
- Well okay.
I mean this, the.
I mean Lukacs is writing in a
Hegelian tradition and Hegel,
in the Aesthetics says that really,
there are like four epics
that actually are epics.
They're the Homeric poems,
he's not quite sure about the Odyssey.
The Homeric poems.
The Mahabharata, the
Ramayana, I'm sorry five.
And the Sit.
Those are the four.
By which he, and excuse me for a second.
And because Germany needs an
epic, maybe the Nibelungenlied.
But that's it.
So epic is very narrowly
defined as being the,
and also for Hegel, it's
the primitiveness of Homer
which is all important to the world
and also the idea is Hegel knows
that the person who wrote, composed.
Excuse me, composed the Homeric poems
is from a later period.
But this person seems to have managed
to completely absorb himself back into
this earlier heroic period
and therefore he is,
and therefore he and his characters
feel absolutely no kinds of
questioning or disconnection
with the world in which they live.
Well, it becomes a problem
when you start reading the Iliad
and the first person you meet is Achilles
who's profoundly you know, disconnected
with his community and
with the world around him.
But this is a kind of romantic world
that is imagined by Hegel
and the very largest
that Lukacs repeats in the opening
of The Theory of the Novel
and that the hero is.
It's a world where everyone
is at home in the world.
Where there's no
dissociation of sensibility,
to use Elliot's term.
But I mean, that's just.
It's clearly not right about these poems
and it is part of a,
it's part of a certain
kind of romantic nostalgia
which is not un,
which is partly a nostalgia
for the Ancien Regime
even by people who were
probably supporters
of the French Revolution but nonetheless
have a kind of deep nostalgia
for this and that's where
a certain kind of romantic
primitivism comes in.
But it seems to be, this is just not.
When one reads the poems,
this is simply not the case.
It's nice for theory
but theory is you know,
when you then actually look at the poems,
they don't work that way.
So that I think, one way is
that the notion of roundedness
and of,
well more of being at
home in the heroic world
is what Hegel wishes and again,
it's partly also nostalgia for faith,
nostalgia for the imminence
of the divine in the world.
It's already called into question by epic
from its beginning.
And that, and I just
think that that's what one
has to just sort of see that in that way,
human nature did not change
in the way that literary,
that this version of literary history
would want to make us think.
Thank you.
- All this talk of banquets
makes me think we should
move on to our reception
in Phelps Hall which
is on the fourth floor
but please join me in thanking David
for a fantastic lecture.
(audience applauds)